[Music]
we have six weeks to harvest a million
crystals and that means you got to move
fast
as soon as harvest starts it's time to
call in the Calvary
[Music]
the state Oregon is the largest supplier
of Christmas trees in the country here
in Oregon Christmas trees outnumber
people twelve to one holiday tree farms
is one of the largest Christmas tree
farms in the world we have about 8
thousand acres of actively growing trees
the only thing we grow is Christmas
trees we sell a million Christmas trees
a year but you got to remember we
harvest them in a very short period of
time we can cut and process a Christmas
tree and have it loaded on a truck in
less than 24 hours the steps in
harvesting a Christmas tree start with
cutting each tree individually with the
chainsaw slingers will pile the trees
and rig them for extraction next we
bring a helicopter and fly them into
waiting trucks each tree is shaken
bailed loaded and in it's on its way to
market
[Music]
although they started using helicopters
in the early 1980s throw a lot faster
than you doing it by hand
the helicopter can harvest met a
thousand fees an hour we normally run
between five or six helicopters everyday
sunup to sundown
[Music]
we've been taking care of these trees
ever since they were very tiny seedlings
an average noble fir is about eight
years old when harvested and six to
seven feet tall
harvest is my favorite time in the year
that's when we get to see the payoff
four six seven eight years worth of work
for every tree that we harvest we plant
another tree in its place so when we
harvest a million trees we plant over a
million trees the neck spring
it never stops so what do I think of
fake trees is a Christmas tree farmer
there are ongoing competition obviously
we're all street farmers I was saying
about fake trees nine years in the house
and nine million years in landfill they
cannot be recycled it's Christmas keep
it
[Music]
these Santa's are all really kids at
heart they like the fun and laughter
that comes with it and making people
happy that's why we're here you ask them
why they're staying up most of them will
tell you because they enjoyed being a
child so they're going back to that
they're reliving your childhood it's a
wonderful thing
welcome everyone to the Charles W Howard
80th anniversary Santa Claus school
[Applause]
[Music]
you better watch out you better not cry
I'm telling you why Santa Claus my name
is Tom Valenti I'm the Dean of the
Charles W Howard is Santa Claus school
in Midland Michigan this is the Harvard
Isana school this is a oldest running
Santa Claus school in the world started
by Charlie Howard in 1937 at Santa Claus
school we learned everything from beard
keeping to personal hygiene toy making
to what it feels like to ride on the
Polar Express flying the sleigh Santa
has to be healthy he's a healthy
outdoorsman if you're not healthy you're
gonna drift off you're not gonna pay
attention it's very important to have
all the skills you can to be a great
Santa because the child is gonna
remember this visit for the rest of your
life when Charlie had to school he had
three or four students some good years
maybe 15 students this year we have 214
it just grows we have Santa's of course
from almost every state in the United
States we have around 20 Santa's from
Canada we have three Santa's from
Denmark one from Norway and one from
Germany there's a real sense of
camaraderie in this school it's like
this large Santa family coming together
they share stories they learn from each
other we want to be seeing us to make
people happy when we get together we're
making each other happy I love it once
they leave this school I hope that each
and every Santa and mrs. Claus goes out
and spreads the spirit of Christmas
spreads the love and joy that we have
here at this school and passes it on to
all the little children and all the
families when you give joy you get it
back to fold
[Music]
so we got you something
Oh what is it come on open it up
oh okay thanks
no honestly this little guy is a big
deal in Catalonia to explain why we got
a head to toe fella de menthe agrees a
town in the Catalonia region of Spain
and to Barcelona a little later but
anyways back to Tahoe le de menthe agree
home to this man known in a way this one
polish yellows the vocalist hey go
what gah gah nests colony una persona
que está siendo shows necesidad a agora
in English at - [ __ ] Peron Quran is from
a p.m. we traditional way and we
catalana in Catalonia when you put up
your nativity scene you have Mary Joseph
of course baby Jesus some Kings and this
guy
yep the Khmer Thomas que hace lo de
hecho para encontrar una súplica Theon
yo tyranny Feliz Navidad es que el campo
portal desert in yellow knob la la
tierra oh no dinero de carne
in Berlin from Port Aventura Milosh were
they so in someone's home there he is in
this museum there he is
well there's even one in this street
nativity scene okay this is definitely
not a joke can we now talk about your
latest business idea
[Music]
Astaire's mark me hermano yes Tom
Barcelona up in the end oh yeah tour
scariness desde que le [ __ ] mascara
Anastos personaje snow Kampala Tico's
food ballistas gente la cultura la
demanda kahani no fue su viendo el
principio un poco de incredulous odd no
de que esto no despues cuando el en un
poquito la tradición pues si la mera no
yatra Munira
a Mucha gente que VA a comprar my
collection is Amira s que tengo un sitio
la parada llevaba
y que cuando voy me quiero sentir
accompany odd oh no he's slobberin olavo
see there you go a gift for all year
round
[Music]
I'm Jen can you guard CEO of king-sized
bows incorporated and welcome to my bow
kingdom we're in the joy business we
make special occasions special I have to
say that our most popular bow is our
signature monarch both the red and
silver one
the Lexus commercials that we've had the
privilege of doing for the last eight
years has really drawn attention to the
multi loop bows we're the only ones in
the United States who actually make
those bows we make them out of a variety
of fabrics and textures and those are
the ones that people are most interested
in there's a whole bow language that
most people don't speak but there are
definitely differences of opinions about
how many loops how long the tails should
be and whether there's a V cut or an
angled cut we are pleased to be in every
showroom from Ferrari to the mini to the
Ford to BMW now we've found that
customers really expect to keep the bow
when they buy the car they want to drive
away with the bow you'd be surprised
where people put bows
it's not just on top of a car anyplace
that you want to say look at me look at
me it can be on a bicycle or a surfboard
or skis on a gate on the top of your
house at a pinnacle
once you put a bow on it it's a present
[Music]
everybody knows jolly old st. Nick
he's the bearer of good tidings and
cheer well in Austria he's not alone and
we don't mean Rudolph
[Music]
these are Krampus a sort of monster that
travels with Saint Nick they scare away
bad spirits and look for naughty kids to
punish making Christmas a whole lot
scarier people in Europe have been
welcoming the Christmas season by
dressing his Krampus for hundreds of
years
I am Ralph Hetzel and I am the oldest
Krampus here in town out Market and the
5th of December we came to the child's
in their homes and the good one gets
some sweets from the Nicolo and the
pepped once get hit with the whip from
the Krampus then we go from house to
house for five six hours and after we
recently to all the children in out mark
there's a little run with all Krampus
together the story of Saint Nick and
Krampus goes back to 375 ad and the
costumes and traditions haven't changed
much since the dress from the Krampus is
made of wool from the Sheep the masks
are made of wood and so when you're
walking around through all the children
to the houses for some hours you really
will get sweat it's like a workout
it's funny to go into the houses from
the people the reaction is different
some childs are not scared come to you
and grab to affair in other ones
screaming and running away the Krampus
is a good reason to change their mind
from the children try to be good for the
next year
I am dressed as Krampus this year the
15-time very lucky to go every year I'm
very proud to be a part of this whole
tradition
[Music]